the Turkish soldiers were stationed in a
recently established military outpost in
tough tenez in Italy province their
death is the second time Turkish
military has come under direct fire in
Italy province earlier this month
eight soldiers were killed in an attack
by Syrian Army in the same area an
escalation that increases the risk of a
full blown military confrontation
between Ankara and Damascus the main aim
is that the ceasefire should be
respected as soon as possible in Italy
the regime must stop its aggression for
a permanent and established ceasefire as
tension grows a sudden counter-offensive
by the rebels they launched an attack to
retake the town of Soraka that is now
under the control of Syrian government
troops as the Turkish back Syrian
National Army fighters were closing in
on Sara Abe artillery bombardment
intensified Turkish army units in Italy
were targeting Syrian troops positioned
in the town while Turkey sends more
troops and vehicles into Italy at an inn
usually fast pace we hope that this
convoy will do what they promised and
force the regime back to where they were
we hope that they will do what is
promised and not to be deceitful
straddling the intersection of the major
and for an m5 motorways that link
government health cities of Damascus
Aleppo and Latakia Sara he could shape
the future of rebel-held territory
adlib is the last rebel-held area in
syria and for many defending the
province is a matter of life or death
the death of the Turkish soldiers in
Edom is likely to put more pressure on
the government here many are waiting to
see if President Recep Tayyip Erdogan
will order a tough response or show
restraint as talks with Russian
diplomats and military officers are
underway in Ankara Hezbollah al jazeera
Istanbul